talk about tone deaf the president's
energy secretary says
americans wouldn't be suffering from gas
or
shortages if they had only bought into
biden's green agenda
we obviously are all in on making sure
that
we meet the president's goals of getting
to 100 clean electricity by 2035
and net zero carbon emissions by 2050
and um you know if you drive an electric
car
this would not be affecting you clearly
and republicans not missing words when
responding to that that was the dumbest
thing in the world if we had all
electric cars
the pipeline hack wouldn't matter well
what if they take down the power company
we could stop demonizing uh fossil fuels
and understand that we cannot run the
greatest economy in all of human history
by putting fairy dust and unicorn urine
in our cars
okay i'll go to you tigers first
berry dust and unicorn urine in the cars
very expensive
do you have an electric car and do you
plan on getting one
i only have electric toothbrush i'm old
school listen i'm all for advancement
uh 235 we ain't there yet i'm just
trying to get through
21 and 22. this is what happens when
elitist out of touch people think
they're helping
you know my grandmother had a great
saying if if was a fifth we'd all be
drunk
this is just pure ignorance and you're
sitting in front of
in the white house telling us well if we
all have electric cars that's like that
riding that guy in the car well if you
want to listen to me and turn left when
i said so
you know what happens to him he gets put
out the car if i was in that
meeting and after that i'd be like you
got a second can you come here for a
second uh you're fired clear out your
desk
please go away like that was just
unbelievably
insensitive ignorant and i expect a lot
more from a woman of her caliber that
was just
really insensitive well there's a lot
more to talk about
when we get to her but dana i'll go to
you i mean
even the energy secretary granholm she
actually
said that the pipeline is the best way
to transport fuel and it appears that
john kerry said something very similar i
mean and and yet
their administration is canceling the
pipeline yeah they cancel the case we
have assad take a listen
okay i think we have the sod here these
are not easy
solutions because there may or may not
be the right uh rail cars there may not
or may not be the
deep water ports available this is why
we have
doubled down on ensuring that there's an
ability to truck
uh oil in gas in but it's
it's the pipe is the best way to go
this is super fantastic super fantastic
because um
look if you are a republican ad maker
they're making their work so easy for
you you just pulled a clip of joe biden
on his first day in office canceling the
keystone pipeline
shoot to a clip of guys down in arkansas
who had jobs and now they were told by
john kerry to get a solar job there are
no solar jobs they can't find jobs
and then you have this whole situation
where first of all
the the hack is what i think the hack is
the bigger issue here
rather than the the fuel the hack is the
issue
because if you have an electric car and
you want to plug that sucker in
and load it up with energy for the next
day
but what happens when uh dark side
decides to hack into our generate our
electricity generation system
or our distribution system that's where
i think the focus should be
fine if they want to try to get to more
electric vehicles but that means you got
to have power in order to do that
but another thing imagine this so
secretary granholm
is a woman is very successful she has
millions in stock in a company that
makes electric car batteries
okay great well where's the media on
this because when biden went to do a big
event
to talk about this program and his plans
and his goals which are lofty and
fine but why would they choose to go
there imagine
if rex tillerson who had been at exxon
and then he comes to work at the state
department for president trump
had used a crisis with iran in order to
make the case for fueling more with
you know gas and basically drilling more
all around
the the media would have lost their
minds the democrats would have gone
crazy and i actually i'm pretty
passionate about energy issues and i
think that
you have to have an energy secretary who
wants all the types of fuel
in abundance so that america can
continue to be a safe
country and one that can be prosperous
as well
okay and so juan what about the fact
that she's got a multi-million dollar
investment the secretary of uh
energy grant home in proterra that the
president took a walk through
and she is promoting that the pipeline
is the best way to transport oil
now is her position shaky in the
administration i mean she's gone against
it and
and we've got some ethical issues there
i i am puzzled but i'm gonna i'm gonna
talk for a second judge and i'll let
anybody
interrupt this time because i'm a little
puzzled first of all i think you guys
are late to the game here
the big car companies have all said they
plan to stop making fossil fuel driven
cars by like twenty thirty twenty thirty
five
go ahead jake
that's great that's great but the
shortage is happening now
and the idea that there's not enough
electric cars i know that that's gonna
be the future we're talking about what's
happening right now
right and also you have a secretary and
what i'm saying is invested
she should divest that well i don't know
but i'm saying
she made these investments long ago she
doesn't need to
she's not trying to promote something to
happen
already the car companies even before
the byte administration came in
made their announcements about the move
towards electric
cars you know on this pipeline business
again i'm
puzzled because the keystone pipeline
wasn't even going to produce
oil for the united states we were
shipping it through the they were from
canada
through the united states down to the
gulf of mexico and it was going to be
exported yeah it is
i've had enough i actually don't i just
want to say that
i just wanted to say that i just wanted
to interrupt go ahead
you're going man i appreciate you i
appreciate it
but here's my thing you had republican
are you let me finish up you had
republican senators today meeting with
president biden on
infrastructure and specifically arguing
you know we want to support
an infrastructure deal but what about
what about we just limit it to roads and
bridges and tunnels
but i think this argument that we're
having here says yay
we want to make sure that our
infrastructure
in terms of things like pipelines in
terms of
traffic lights in terms of so you know
media
transfer one of those polls that have
the the
cell phone post all that are protected
that's a that's a different argument i
think for republicans to hear an
expanded vision of what is interesting
one want what we're talking about you
can harden the electric grid
and right now jesse i'm gonna go i'm
gonna go to you but the truth is there
are people
who can't afford a new car okay and all
of this
forcing people you know out of a job
with a pipeline to energy nobody's got a
job yet
and now people have to buy a new car
jesse hit it
juan do you have an electric car no
no why not one
i was i asked you for a loan remember
that
okay exactly it's a boutique vehicle
only two percent of all the vehicles on
the road are electric
and i bet you could start in the western
side of virginia
drive down the north carolina through
south carolina into north georgia
county after county you probably
wouldn't see one
electric car for sale at a dealership
not
a single one and not only that i don't
think you'd see a single charging
station
and let's just say you live in a city
and you don't have a garage and you park
on the street like most people
where are you putting the charging
station juan ever think of that
so i mean these things are particularly
lots of them and how are you going to
charge the charging station
you're going to use either or natural
gas the two things that the democrats
have declared war on
go make sense gotta go hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else